your lesson Island as we know yeah so
what's it like going into next season um
because a bit alone yeah yeah I mean I
know who's left for who's dead who's
alive um you know they really keep us in
the dark we don't get our scripts to
probably about three or four days before
we start shooting um as far as I know
I'm still working season but I would not
anything happy you know they call you up
like a hey whether you dine episode one
just don't let you know but um no I
think you know a lot of us will survive
and you know come back and try to pick
up the pieces and the fallout of that
ending know so I don't want to spoil it
for anybody with it um but yeah you know
I think it's gonna be a great season the
way we ended is really gonna lead off to
some real cool things for season six and
I think you see it's really dealing with
that ending like in a really in-depth
way you had one of the fun favorites
come back from an earlier season before
you joined echo and of course Slade
Wilson played by money Bennet and what
was it like working with him on the
stairs and and how did you enjoy that
character being part of the show again
yeah I um
for me my favorite episode of arrow is
the penultimate episode of season two
when he got s'more with spoiler alert if
you haven't seen that um and so just to
see him come back and to get to be a
part of that in any capacity he was like
really like nerd heaven for me I love
that character I love my new um him and
the Slade and you know the Green Arrow's
history is just so awesome and vivid and
brutal you know and so for him to come
back in this capacity for me when I
first read it it just like goosebumps
and chills and there's just like so dope
that they were able to pull it off um
and I think the fans really responded
well to it and I just you know the end
of this season was just like I couldn't
believe I was a part of something so
cool like that the question had your own
kind of behind the scenes on arrow
storyline with your with your husband
Paul haven't here we come in watching
how that's coming
you're expecting a different outcome
than perhaps you know everyone else
might have been how do you think that
will go forward now yeah you know I
think for Curtis moving forward with the
Paul situation he's going to kind of
have to find himself you definitely
still lost Paul and wants to make it
work but I think it's going to have to
get out in the field in a different
capacity you date a little bit see what
else is out there and then see if you
can if possible rekindle is relationship
but your wcm move on in some capacities
from that because there's been a big
matchmaker this season as well as okay
yeah bringing back eliciting what your
feelings on olicity because some fans
love it sometimes not so much you know
for me um coming onto the show you know
as Curtis and getting to work with Emily
bad you know I just love courtesies and
Felicity's relationship and so it makes
perfect sense to me that Curtis would
definitely be like throw that and like
really forward and I think olicity is
really great you know um it just depends
on you know exactly how its executed and
I think I really love how they executed
that relationship this season how they
still you know focus a lot of action
what's going on but that he does that
still is that heart there you know and I
think that's important so I really like
where they're going with it I love it
Curtis is like so amped to like hook
them up and you make it work whether
it's a Chinese food or whatever you know
it that's it's just so fun to play a
character like that with so much like
optimism and just you know good vibes
cuz I don't know somebody can cut and
now roll
baddest for today's a little tea or
juice or providing industry button I
mean I writers are really great I think
they really get it you know they get the
comedy and they get the dramatic stuff
and they let us play you know but I
really credit them really for their
amazing writing but they do let us out
live and have fun with it and I come
from a big improv background
so basically anytime I can find it and
they're very like go for that go which
is really cool my definite like to play
around you know and go plays especially
with Rick Rick and I love just riffing
on different things so definitely add a
lotta improv there but it really doesn't
need to be in there cuz the writers are
like they're so legit yeah they do
you're not going to get more clearly to
become a seasoned regular I'm sure often
just done but guessing for talked about
in previous yeah I mean the dream come
true you know I feel so fortunate to be
even gifted the ability or chance to
work on the show and for them to think I
was doing such a good job and the fans
to feel that way to them that ask me to
stick around permanently I mean it's
just stuff you know you wish you could
have in your life and you know I still
pinch myself because I really do love
the show and it's actually a show I've
been on a couple shows and none of my
friends watch those shows I like them
but they love arrow and the whole DC
Universe and everything like that so
it's definitely a dream come true to get
to be able to be a focal point of the
show you know to actually be planted
into the show and to be one of the
characters that they focus on every
episode well these are you go into the
house you know it was an already
established core group yeah I mean I
honestly I thought they were all be
jerks when a person is like they're
gonna be all mean and like oh we've been
here for three years to get out of here
but they were also down earth and humble
and funny and silly and it's just it's
still what we carried throughout the
show I honestly think is one of the
funnest shows I've ever been on as far
as just working with people like we just
laugh so much before every take
play pranks and jugs and it's such a fun
environment to work on a set the crew
they really let us have fun you know so
it was nerve-racking coming in like I
did not know what to expect but all that
was just pushed aside and just a lot of
openness and love there
tell me the pranks we've heard from
other people shows that John Barrowman
is the master even baratunde and yet
other pranking dirty shoes yeah I made
everybody on the kerosene barrels but
you know like he loves to do surprise
but attack um but yeah he he's very he's
very funny I cannot say the pranks he
does outside of that and there are all
much worse than that
x-rated if you know but he really like
um season four I work with him the last
two episodes I didn't work with my all
season two last two episodes and he made
such a huge impact on me in those last
two episodes because he does like to
have fun and he has so much energy but
as soon as they call action he's the
most professional like gifted man
they're you know I'm saying so just
learning how he takes the love and the
fun of the craft but still apply the
professional aspect to it is like
something that I'm like I want to hone
in on that and like really get that to a
point like he does so people sound
familiar with a fireman but attack can
you just walk through the mechanics of
houses like you know like you're you
doing a scene and you're like okay um
you're like rehearsing and like you turn
around and Malcolm Merlyn has butt out
and you'd like oh this or like what do
you guys doing you know stuff like that
you know that's like that's a easy
surprise but at that you know Sam but
it's a lot
we all are pretty dirty and raunchy on
set you know like I wish I could tell
you something too jokes or play or each
other with the backlight and we coming
in chasing and the backlight and mr.
terrific has a history in comic yeah
would you let say like these scenes of
black character no of course yeah I
would love to do scenes of crash I met
him a couple days ago we had to do like
a mondo shoot but yeah they like in the
comic books they like had a connection
to each other like being two of you know
only african-american
you know uh superheroes so like that
that is something I would love to see
addressed and I mean I know they they
kind of mentioned that it might not be a
part of the arrowverse do you know
anything's possible
let's be real like you know Supergirl
was not a part of the arrow verse right
you know since so I think all these
things are moving pieces and fluid and
so I think it could be a possibility I
would love to see it you know I also
love to see like I I you know it's a
terrific had connections with Black
Canary and all these characters and so
the JSA and like that so I would love to
see them mix it up with a lot of
different characters and you know even
legends and you know all that stuff now
acting more like a nice to spend enough
part in beginning a Hanukkah to be like
next page you know and kind of what
enjoy that which that female black
absolutely yeah I would really love to
see Curtis coming to his own as a
fighter and really getting out there in
the field I mean he's definitely
starting to contribute more with having
created the T spirit but I definitely
seen been out there and Shaw badass is
the actual practical of pine of it like
even Stephen Amell is math like it takes
like 20 minutes to apply still you know
like so practically none of it makes
sense
um but yeah I did ago but yeah I mean um
I think that's definitely like something
with dressing next year in a not so
subtle way but like I won't be wearing
braids next year um and we're just
trying to make the mask more efficient
and just help the process you know like
when Grant first armor flash it was like
this one piece that could not be moved
and was glued on it took like hours and
now you know it's very simple and so
like that so it kind of just this fluid
motion kind of going on and I feel like
as far as the cannon goes you know uh
Marx has some really funny is like
Curtis is a metahuman his only ability
as he breaks his hair instantly so I
like yeah see I I was sent as an African
speech or somewhere that people don't
know about it so I'm going to do it
um but Terry simple if you could have
created some machine or something like
that to that did it really quick you
know but I don't they hopefully they
address it I hoping to do that
give me does this hilarious meme where
it alls like suit up and it was like
yeah he's like mister and then Curtis
was like linking my brain to my contacts
it's two hours later and I was like I'm
gonna kill humans that's a really funny
me would you like more crossroads
because of massive invasion crossover
would you like something more next piece
in this way yeah absolutely those
crossovers are some of the most fun I
know for me personally reading comic
books that was when I was at peak
nerdiness like you know when the
crossovers happened and different
characters from different segments would
interact with each other and take on a
big bath so for me that's like comic
book heaven and to see us actually to be
part of it to see it to be alive you
know when this is happening and the
cinematic world is like so dope and so
cool so I love to see it I want to see
it more and more and more obviously it's
really tough with everyone's schedules
to you know just create that time so we
all can't do it and still you know be on
our own shows but I'm down for any
process that they want to get that ideal
scenarios you could have anyone in that
crossover and anything happen what would
you like to see happen in that next
crossover which obviously you're going
to get yeah you know I'd like to see mr.
terrific lead everyone uh you know know
I mean you know for me um god I mean
invasion was so good you know yeah I
would love for them to you know take on
like some big bad like dark city or a
dark side or somewhere like that it
would be so cool like to just you know
really go for it and yeah I just want to
see I I love any of the crossovers I
mean whether it was a you know invasion
or when a legend came or on or whatever
it's it's just epic you know and so I
just wanted to get bigger and bigger and
bigger if you could solve the conundrum
of what's going to happen and that after
that cliffhanger episodes obviously
there's been lots of speculation online
has ley taking them to the bunker for
example how would you solve it if you
had some colorful how occurred to solve
and how would you solve is well I think
Curtis would have brought like tea
spirits or everyone to fly out of that
joint you square
blew up uh me personally I would have
solved it by not going to island like no
we're not doing that I don't trust no
island uh uh volcano just made them no
ah
that's real job what do you think of
that fan series its leaves take them to
the bunker they're all video right now
yeah her like you know same it is taking
them to the Argus bunkers and select
that or possibly they fix the plane
enough time to get off um I think
they're pretty good pretty good
fan series I think they're definitely
within the realm of plausibility yes I
mean it can definitely happen it's up to
the writers and you know who knows what
they're listening are you guessing you
said you only get the script so many
days before are you guessing winds like
they on the penultimate or the one
before that script you thinking how they
going to get out of this yeah yeah
definitely we definitely uh one of those
things also we wanted like I hope my dad
tell my dad you know so your eyes up and
do that too but yeah it is something as
a fan you know I am I read the scripts
once when I try to forget them so I can
like watch it and like be invested and
live in it but it definitely reading
them was like you know at the edge of my
seat mouth agait like whoa like I
couldn't believe he was happening but I
was just like so geeked out that slaves
coming back that was like the man they
were just like oh my god Slade Wilson's
back holy SH you know know what and I'm
the worst spoiler like I spoil
Prometheus at the beginning of the year
they use Josh and nobody saw and I was
like oh thank god ah so it's tough for
me to keep my lips like seal somewhat
hmm just please err who let this out
like please I just don't want the
pressure so yeah
she believes that Malcolm Merlyn is
going to be dead what do you think he do
you think he's got out of there
somewhere like I'm living by telling
been going onto the line well all I can
say is if you don't see a body play ball
yeah that's alright that's how I look at
it um I think there's always room I mean
I think there's a room for him to come
back for sure
you know um and thing can happen
especially in these universes you know
so I would not say in things final scene
are individual and are they going to
bring bring in that fast
vigilance II would definitely come back
I
I have no ideas in any way to perform
the vigilante is all of us is what I
tell people we're all of them honestly
talk about the crossovers you're excited
fans excited about that but I think
there's a sense that I mean with the
combinations we've already seen there's
kind of you know where do you go from
there how do you make it bigger than
what you've already done
you have a sense of kind of how they can
talk what they've already done with that
you know um that's very interesting
right every year an arrow it's a bigger
and bigger kind of thing that's
happening with the city now in the world
nukes and I think one of the cool things
you saw about season 5 is they want the
opposite spectrum it wasn't this big
city is more of a personal thing so I
think they could definitely switch it up
on people and it doesn't have to be this
big you know huge thing it could be a
more of a really personal tragedy that
they are dealing with that could be
interesting to you know you know what I
mean like it could inverse on itself and
we could probably create something
really amazing from within that because
I really love how season 5 really took a
different tilt from that whole those
cities in danger you know the worlds and
dangerous type of thing is really like
personal for what's going on Oliver in
the team and I don't think they can
spend that - with the crossovers
you